okay so um I didn't I did if till he
didn't die in the first round and it
totally didn't happen this time for
realsies
I'm not a scrub I swear so now okay I I
didn't cheat okay all right all right
see you guys are gonna think I cheated I
did not I played and you would not
believe the things look at my popularity
ranking you would not believe it I came
across something that offered me 50
popularity for a 25% chance I'll go back
it was true I pushed it
I won it and I am not in the right where
the no hang on
wait no your gosh [ __ ] you what the [ __ ]
happened okay yeah there we okay hang on
everybody hold your freaking horses
because okay alright
so it's true I'm in the wrong room but
don't blame me random item plus critical
yay yay
okay get mystery box stuff good god
okay so you guys are not gonna believe
me but I'll port there right now I went
to it's true 100% true I guarantee I'm
not bullshitting it's it was right here
yes this okay see it was okay alright
like apparently I could push this again
I don't want to risk it I'm already at a
hundred but I pushed it for you to show
you that it happened okay so that's fine
I did it so now I'm gonna get past this
boss and I'm gonna get over to the area
that you guys a [ __ ] wrong way I've got
to get past this boss I'm very popular
right now I'm gonna able to get back to
the third level
so that I could make some goddamn
progress now what the oh god whoa whoa
[ __ ] you god damn it this is going very
poorly I don't know why
shouldn't be these guys easy okay all
right I got okay get that get that
what's an ERP something good god damnit
lockpicks okay alright alright okay
we're okay I'm super popular I am a
goddamn hero I get 50 for accuracy okay
what did you guys get me what is that
actually popular photo the kid who
bullied you at school all right okay oh
my god you guys are gonna pick lunacy
for the next one oh geez funny oh god I
love it
okay I'm gonna get more defense I'm
gonna get more damage I'm gonna get more
armor cuz apparently that's hard to come
by all right come on bring it on what do
you got for me nothing that's what you
got a lot of nothing what is bad what
are those okay got that taken care of
holy [ __ ] whoa Oh God the mushrooms are
kicking in real bad oh god I can't oh
yes yeah okay this is good that's good
that's good having a bit bit but can't
kill me right what is this random weapon
all right sure hey this looks cool why
does it only have five whoa I think
orangey may have Bubber knocked me on
this one okay but I'll give him a try oh
that's pretty cool okay so it's not
actually just okay
oh she's joy yeah yeah okay this is
actually pretty good
whoa jeez oh jeez
oh okay so they just go in a spray
$7,000 budget cuts I don't know what
that means
okay oh geez mystery box hello damn it
[ __ ] oh that's not good okay gotta move
gotta move gotta move okay yeah Boesky
oh geez
what the [ __ ] what am I stuck on uh
Jesus goddamn it I need to stop
reloading like that I don't need to
reload why do I keep reloading oh cool I
just got these so that means I got more
ammo that's good okay I don't mind I'm
having a real bad trip here like real
woohee okay you got it
okay whoa jeez ow [ __ ] man this weapon
is really good out out [ __ ] no you do
not don't do that [ __ ] to me [ __ ] the
mushrooms oh boy
god damnit [ __ ] those icicles you are
not gonna kill me dude no yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you okay oh jesus
yes health please yes tiny bits of
health oh yes health thank you oh god I
don't want to say I'm a dick I'm a bit
of a dick but I don't want to say it out
loud
oh maybe maybe I'll get help maybe I'll
get help from you guys I'm a hero after
all
oh boy oh boy I knew it you're not the
first and definitely won't be the last
contestant went crazy during killing
room but don't worry soon you will rest
in peace you're hearing and seeing
things thank you oh thank you oh thank
you very much you guys are so nice oh
you're so nice oh boy I need more max
health you do more damage I need more
armor I need a lot of things the hammer
ain't doing so good oh why is there a
pony here why
okay I'm on shrooms and I'm seeing
things
oh well I didn't reload cuz why would I
do that I'm I'm such a dummy
okay we're gonna try so hard god I can't
well that's not good okay gangster style
oh boy
well that just hit me okay wasting all
my ammo oh hi oh hey oh hey hi okay
that's weird okay goodbye thank you for
visiting oh oh come on no no no no no no
no don't you I didn't shoot the robot
why are these guys so impossible
good god okay gotta buy this gotta buy
this gotta buy random item gonna be good
you're lucky sometimes you kill enemies
with the first hit cool whoo Wow indeed
this okay I am dying and this is bad I
only have my pistol and I'm seeing
clowns this is going very poorly for me
I don't have enough weaponry Oh
invisible stairs does that mean oh I
don't know what that means
invisible oh ah okay so I got to find
the stairs so what I got to do or do I
got to make stairs oh god this isn't oh
this isn't good for me oh god oh god
there's no way I'm not gonna make this
oh people are gonna hate me and then I'm
gonna see more clowns and ponies are
gonna fly by my face
I am so boner owned not gonna work not
gonna work is it oh geez not gonna work
well nope not gonna work
oh [ __ ] dude I wasn't ready for this
nope daddy that's not that's the
opposite of okay well puzzle finals
alright hi welcome you want to join me
on this next one oh why here get out
here oh no not you settings you settings
you're talking about my settings
settings options three zero zero one
okay alright three zero zero one what is
that I got a wasp
Sandman did okay what do we got here we
got a whole assortment of stuff whoo
that looks good okay see Ryan's baby or
this what's probably a plasma or Frost
launcher I'm gonna take Ryan's baby okay
then the others exploded also I'm gonna
try to open up this thing even though
people don't want me to disturb the dead
I can't [ __ ] this one up yeah geez you
you you
hi thanks for the luck okay so I got a
weapon I got some health I'm almost to
the boss area I'm doing okay I'm not
doing great but I'm doing okay I just
want to be able to use Ryan's baby and
blast some enemies away
okay got that one easy enough okay so I
got about as much health as I'm gonna
get so I guess it's time to go for this
as much as people don't really like me
right now I gotta fight a boss we're
finally do a new boss this is the only
thing I really wanted here so we're
doing good
hi oh oh oh god why is it gonna be worm
it's gonna be a bigot isn't it
oh god clown oh that's a lot of people
that didn't make it through this one hi
okay
a good one that probably is gonna work
insulting oh god of course
oh great time for the shrooms to kick in
all right until I know exactly what I'm
up against I'm gonna use my pistol oh
that's that's not good why
I hit the butthole oh Jesus okay that's
that's not good oh geez I gotta move oh
it's got it's got things on the sides oh
okay yeah oh okay I'm seeing it okay now
that I know kind of generally what's it
oh you're just gonna poop out more worms
softly nice but please don't kick oh
jesus what was that
oh you're fast ow [ __ ] who's doing that
oh oh it's you Oh God god damn it oh
that's not good
ah not the best time not the best time
ah I gotta hit it in the holes ow
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
holy [ __ ] come on no I'm so close why
now oh Jesus
I would have been the end of me come on
come on yes oh Jesus although those
gonna kill me oh my god I'm on shrooms
and everything's horrible quick hands
oh thank you Automag reserved reloading
that's so nice and what is this oh yes
oh yes oh yes all right okay this is
good
this is good I don't even need to say
I'm a dick I got a better pistol which
has been the only thing that I've been
using this whole time and I'm still a
hero I get double jump hill yeah
and then ammo capacity is increased hell
yeah oh my god what did you guys give me
oh thank you I get double jump in that
oh that's so nice oh that's so nice oh
you guys are so nice oh you guys are so
nice I'm gonna re-roll this to something
more interesting woo woo oh geez that's
not good but it's it's a nice statue
okay I will do that one oh boy that's
what I need I was so slow that was my
problem wasn't able to ever do anything
so I have very few bad idea
besides the lunacy ones but I got a lot
of good items so I'm going to save an
exit here because holy [ __ ] I want to
keep going on that one so thank you for
helping me thank you for hindering me so
thank you everybody who helped out and
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you thought of this
down in the comments below I had a lot
of fun with it it was really cool to
have you guys helping me out and
whatever way there was to help out
hopefully I can do this in the
livestream at a future point so you can
see and effect it right on screen but
thanks again everybody so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]